everyone mmm so I guess first off let's
go who am i what do I do
so I'm Jesse Brizzy I'm a research
engineer at a startup called Kira light
basically it means I'm a a computer
vision machine learning engineer at the
company my main background is in
computer science but I do a lot of focus
on computer vision machine learning it
machine learning what does the company
do that's relevant to machine learning
so we are a ecommerce SAS company
basically the one sentence blurb is our
platform enables brands to find image by
find image based social media content
and repurpose it for e-commerce purposes
specifically I'm on the image
intelligence team which owns the entire
pipeline of researching new machine
learning ideas for applications
developing it training it researching it
and then getting out it it out in inter
production we're pretty small startup so
we're pretty scrappy at it one good
example of a product that we do with
machine learning is our intelligent
product tagging software so basically
it's a technology that analyzes imagery
and uses machine learning to identify
specific products depicted within that
image from our clients brand catalog so
this next slide I have a just kind of
video demonstration of it if you want to
go through it so as you can see we have
the image on the right we identify the
objects in the image and we match those
specific objects with products from the
client catalog that we have previously
ingested and run through our system to
identify with very interesting problems
pretty fun to work out this isn't the
only thing we do ml on we do a couple
other things but I'm not here to sell my
company I'm here to help you figure out
what kind of deep learning library you
want to use so working on Keralite and
doing all this machine learning stuff
for a while I've had the unfortunate
experience of working my way through a
few of these to kind of figure out which
one we wanted to use in which one we
wanted to commit to we've used a couple
for a year real like years realized it
was just a pain to maintain and use in
our production stack and to kind of do
research and train with so we I think
two years ago or like one year and a
half ago we went on a kind of paper
review of the current state of
deep learning libraries and kind of
figure out what we wanted to commit to
and along the way we kind of learned a
lot of things about what we should
really be looking out for and like
what's important in a deep learning
library and kind of the quality of life
things you want to deal with day to day
in terms of your I guess entire wor work
pipeline so hopefully this talk can give
you some insight of what we learned and
will help you make the similar decision
yourself if that's something you're
looking to do and you may find out that
more than one of these might actually
work well for you so just kind of a good
introduction for the people who are like
completely new here just so we're not
clear loss of Thakker names what is a
neural network so basically so basically
a neural network or artificial neural
network is a machine learning model that
is modeled after biological neural
networks basically think of the brain
where on the right you can see is
abstracted out to basically a series of
nested functions or each individual node
or neuron inside the network does a
simple task and when they're all
collected together and it layers you
have your input on the Left output on
the right it can learn to do a task
mathematically there destructured as
nested functions with weights and the
those weights are trained via button
back propagation they can be as simple
as this network here with only one
hidden layer what's the hidden layer is
layer on the inside the exposed layers
are the input in the output or they can
be as crazy deep with like hundreds of
layers and millions of parameters I'll
need a train
so some acronyms that you're going to
see when people are talking about neural
networks so you have your FC ends or
your fully connected neural network so
these are kind of your basic multi-layer
perceptrons so you have your network
with multiple layers in it or all the
nodes inside the layers are connected to
all the previous nodes and the previous
layer well when you start adding layers
to this and start getting deeper and
deeper and deeper to kind of get more
pretty good more predictive power out of
your model the weights can start to add
up and kind of get unruly which is where
the next type of model comes in CN NS or
convolutional neural networks especially
when it comes to the area of computer
vision since images can be fairly large
inputs
you think of each individual pixel as an
input to your let to your network where
instead of having a fully connected
layer each layer are contained of
convolutional layers where each
convolutional kernel or filter is a
collection of weights that's convolve
over each layer where the levee your
input or the hidden layers on the inside
where all the weights are shared between
between all the kernels so you can think
of it as say you have a neural network
that's good at identifying cars you may
have a kernel that's good at identifying
wheels and it'll involve over the entire
input space of your image to help find
those wheels and then the layer layers
we'll do some more deeper semantic
knowledge with that information that it
was able to identify you have your RN
ends which are recurrent neural networks
these are neural networks that feed back
into themselves so they're really useful
for temporal problems mainly used in
natural language processing tasks
they're kind of basic but they can be
used for other temporal things like
stock data or like just basically any
time series that you need to predict on
then you have your LS TMS which are
basically fancy neural networks there I
mean fancy RN ends there long short-term
memory recurrent neural Nets basically
think of it like a recurrent neural net
that is able to determine what is
important and not important to remember
there are gates on the inside that it
can decide what information that it
gleaned at this certain time stopping
your temporal data for it to remember
for the next iterations as it goes on
through whether it be your text sequence
or your stock data that's flowing in or
whatever your time series data is so
know that's out of the way let's go over
the important factors that everyone
should be really looking for when
they're selecting a library to work with
and probably the biggest thing that you
need to look for in the beginning is who
is library kind of targeted at so you
have your academia focus libraries and
then you have like your industry focus
libraries depending on who you are
they're gonna offer our certain features
or kind of a certain quality of working
with it that will be better for you the
community support this is honestly a big
thing so how easy
is it to find pre-trained models for
whatever tasks you're trying to do so
say you're trying to do something as
simple as like spam filtering or do
semantic tagging or just classification
on images there are a lot of pre trained
networks that people might produce
publicly that are already done for this
so if you have a very popular library
they're using there's probably going to
be a higher chance of these people
creating the models for you and you can
just download that and go along your way
and you don't actually do any training
or anything how often our research paper
is reproduced in your library of choice
in a open source manner so for like a
lot of the kind of new and great
research that comes out of conferences
there are going to be open source
implementations of those research papers
available on github or bitbucket or
whatever I want to use for your source
management and basically if you want to
use like this new layer or this new
model structure if someone's already
gone through the trouble of making an
open-source equivalent for you it's
pretty simple then you can just kind of
pull down that model and then go
training right away with your own data
if you want to repurpose it for your own
domain specific tasks and of course how
Google or like the bugs are gonna be
running into so if you run into an issue
which you will run into an issue working
with these especially if you're trying
to get into a production environment how
common is it gonna be that someone else
is already run into your problem that's
gonna give you a solution on something
like psych overflow or something
there's gonna be the development
barriers to getting into it so how good
is the documentation how low level or
high level is the library is it gonna
have you doing a lot of needless like
boilerplate and like magic number work
when you're trying to get your network
together or is it just kind of like the
three line thing to get your network
training and running how many supported
programming languages and especially if
it supports the language of your choice
for doing your training or research or
getting into your production environment
and the ability to scale which is gonna
be more on the production side of things
but if you want to be able to scale it
up to a massive cluster of GPUs how well
does it do that can it even do that in
the first place and how performing is it
the code base quality so you want to use
a library that is actively maintained
you don't want to be like file a bug and
I never get addressed for a year because
there's no one actually they're working
on it so the more actively maintained it
is the better and performance here's an
oldest benchmark I'll go over it more in
detail later on but basically you want
to have good performance for whether
working on GPUs multiple GPUs if you're
working specifically on CPUs or even
down to mobile platforms and each
library offers a very kind of different
performance that you can expect
especially for the type of neural
network and testing you're trying to do
so that's a key thing to be pay
attention to so the last thing to really
mean to think about is the train to
production pipeline that you're going to
be looking at so say you want to have a
library that can support a faster
prototype of language that you use for
like research and testing things out so
like Python and R but your deployment
language that you have for your
production environment is something like
a JVM language like Java or Scala or at
C++ or Java Script if you're trying to
throw it up on the web
something so ideally you can train it
locally on your hardware and then push
it out to your production environment
just very simple even though completely
different environment or even on the
cloud service as if it's already
integrated and set up for it and you
want to be able to run it locally in on
mobile phones massive server farms and
also ideally have the ability to take
your work to other libraries so say you
get tired of your library you want to
leave it one day hopefully you can
transfer it out and into the new library
and they offer or support at least that
kind of functionality so one main thing
you have to look out for with your
neural net library choice is difference
between the imperative and symbolic kind
of paradigms for defining the nuts they
each have their own disadvantage and
advantage so let's start off dynamic
paradigm for defining computation graphs
or your networks it's basically you can
think of it just kind of as most
standard programming languages to work
basically as the library goes through
your code kind of like on the right you
can see here some example numpy code it
basically computes it as it sees it the
advantage of this is that it makes
prototyping and debugging very easy so
you can stick random
like debug statements print statements
inside your model definition if it's in
a dynamic paradigm it's very useful when
your graph structure needs to change
while it's running so some networks and
pasted on the input will change the
structure of the network itself for
whatever the output is it tends to be a
lot more flexible it's easier to use
native language features so if you like
for loops and python or if you're like
doing any like list comprehensions stuff
in your fancy languages and the graph of
your network can just kind of follow the
logical flow of your program that you're
writing out for it now on the other side
is you have your symbolic paradigms
which kind of addresses some of the
negatives with a dynamic paradigm so
when you have a dynamically defined
graph in your library it can't do a lot
of optimizations that will help in terms
of speed which might be very important
for your production environment so with
symbolic paradigm is you define
everything about your graph before it's
ran so on the right you can see you
could be equivalent numpy code where you
will define your entire computation and
then you will compile it and then call
the function itself and you'll replace
the variables with whatever your input
data is now the advantage of this is
that it allows the library to optimize
your nets for you to do things like
reuse memory if it sees that Oh in the
earlier stages of this network we use
this one memory position but later on
it's dumped and never referenced again
so we can just reuse it in place
especially for memory is a require is a
constrained resource on your system
whereas in the dynamic paradigm when it
sees you use a variable it doesn't know
if you're everyone you need again so has
to keep it around the entire time until
you manually dump it yourself and it's a
lot easier for handling the network
itself so especially in a production
environment when you need to load in
your net and unload your net and kind of
move it around with things especially if
you're worried about your resources that
you have to deal with knowing exactly
when you compile and initiate the
network when it will take up the
resources and every single time it will
always take the same amount of memory is
a kind of nice thing to have and like I
said it can optimize the graph let's
start and it's generally good for
feed-forward fixed nets so you're free
for full connector neural nets and your
cnn's whereas the dynamic paradigms
useful for LS TMS and your RN ends
because they kind of change as it goes
along so first thing going to go over is
generally the libraries that you people
most people should know about and if
you're making a decision these are the
libraries that you'll probably select
from so getting started IMO one of the
first mainstream production-ready
libraries is cafe on the right I will
have these kind of useful charts here
basically I will share the slides at the
end of the day and they have useful
links that you can go out and click
yourself if you're more interested in
curious to learn more but basically it
has things like the github current stats
for watches stars and forks how long it
basically average issues are resolved
and how many open issues there are to
kind of get an idea of like how
maintained the codebase is the type of
paradigm that the API interface uses up
at top we'll have a bunch of icons for
what api's are available language wise
for example for cafe we have Python C++
and MATLAB and we'll have links up to
the model Zoo if you want to see what
models are pre-trained and available for
you to work with and also just the
number of research citations on the
right if you want to kind of get an idea
of how actively used these libraries are
in the research community so back to
cafe so cafe is one of the early and my
like and then like I said one of the
first mainstream product already
libraries out there it's very high
performant and has a very well tested
C++ code base it was one of the first
and of started the concept of a model
zoo where people publicly put up their
models to share with other people if
they wanted to reuse it for other
purposes for it has a pretty large
community of open-source research
projects given that it was so early a
lot of people latched on to it you're
not going to see numbers that high for
research citations for any of you of
other libraries some are catching up
though it's very good for feed
feed-forward neural networks and like
image processing it was originally
designed to do work with CNN's you're
gonna actually get going without writing
any code at all
they provide a pretty verbose but useful
kind of like config
interface where you just kind of define
some cook config files put your data in
a certain format and a folder run a
binary and along you go it's training
the code for you without ever writing
that single line of Python or something
its main advantage was that it was kind
of the first to market so everybody kind
of latched on to it started doing
research and the people started doing
research based off that research and it
kind of kept expanding into its own
network effect and in most libraries are
capable of converting from Caffe into
themselves because they all recognize
that this is a lot where a lot of people
are coming from so if we want to attract
more people over we have to support cafe
as an incoming source now it's not all
that like like all great things so it
has some bad design choices that are
inherited just because from its original
you case which was specifically
convolutional neural networks and also
first-to-market so it made a lot of
mistakes that people learn to not do
later on it's not really that great for
recurrent neural networks it can do it
but it's kind of like how hacked on
afterthought and it's kind of clunky to
work with it does not support Auto
differentiation which is a big thing so
whenever you define your network you
also have to manually do the math and
define the gradients and do all the
calculus for the back pass over your
network for training which can be a
little annoying
and as for finding new layers it can be
very verbose and kind of annoying
because you have to actually go down
into the raw C++ and CUDA to define new
layers in cafe if you want to add them
in now it's possible to do it in Python
but then it backs out of the C++ library
and slows everything down to the point
where it's not really that great to use
and the graph itself so just kind of
treated as a collection of layers not
necessarily like the individual nodes
and the basically each layer does a
common set of math functionality that
you can just reuse and reuse and reuse
to create your entire graph but like I
said it's a bit of a pain to write new
layers for one of the other important
libraries that I need to introduce
before we get to the other ones is chaos
so chaos is not a deep learning library
on its own it is a library that sits on
top of other deep learning libraries it
provides a single easy-to-use high-level
interface it's very modular minimal
readable object-oriented code and it's
great for beginners
documentation so basically if you're
trying to get it started as fast as
possible and you don't really care how
things work on on the inside just go
with chaos and you'll be pretty happy it
lacks in its optimizations this since
it's basically built on top of other
deep learning libraries so it can't
actually create a graph structure that
is efficient because it has to be
adaptable to all of them it has
supported backends mainly for tensor
flow in theano it also supports the in
Takai and there's a branch that supports
MX net I'll get to all these later on in
their own right the nice thing about
chaos is that after you define and train
your model in this simple interface you
can actually export your model in
whatever underlying back-end format you
used so say you use the simple chaos
interface to define your neural net you
trained it and everything you can
actually just export a tension flow
model out and then load that back into
whatever tends to flow environment
you're working with in fact because of
this tensor flow actually includes a
fork of chaos inside their own library
to use if you're using the Python API
chaos itself it's only Python and
actually it's also our I forgot to add
in the our logo up top when issues that
like I said it's not it you can't
optimize as much it's not as
customizable and sometimes when you're
doing more advanced things with all
networks you'll have to drop down into
the underlying library to do some things
and it gets a little weird when you do
that because you're mixing like for
example we're all tensorflow code with
Kaos code and kind of like that weird
so probably the one that most people
already know about is tensorflow
it is by far the most popular option out
there for doing deep learning it has the
largest active community and probably
more open source projects use to enter
flow than anything else it has support
for all these languages up here so
python r c++ and go javascript c-sharp
java in rust i on the right here i'll
also have some links out to code
examples basically all these links out
to a fairly helpful github repo where
they've collected together a list
of common tasks all done in each library
so you can compare and contrast how
simple it is and how different it is to
do for example CNN training and of
classification in all these libraries to
maybe help your decision process
basically tensorflow is Google's attempt
of basically solving everything that
they can in the deep learning kind of
environment they have built it with
massive distributed computing in mind
basically it powers all of the Google
apps out there are powers YouTube
empowers Google Maps Google Translate
the assistant it is able to actually
even run on mobile platforms in fact
tensorflow they have this kind of
problem where they keep coming up with
new extensions to do things they have
like two different light versions of
tensorflow to run on mobile devices in
the form of constructs on mobile and
tensorflow light they developed tensor
board which is this honestly amazing
debugging and like visualization
platform so basically you can visualize
the entirety of your deep net inside
this visualization tool you can follow
gradients as it propagates through the
network and can monitor your training
progress to see the lost functions and
like the actual output of the Nets as
its learning to do whatever your task is
it has Center flow serving which is
useful for prod deployments it's only
Python but basically it's a kind of easy
one-step drop-in solution for you take
your model you throw it in there and it
exposes a REST API so you can easily hit
and get results from your model with
very little coding to get it up and
there is a lot of documentation from
Google which is actually pretty good
documentation for Google and also a lot
of third-party documentation just
because of how popular it is in the
community it's used by companies like
uber Airbnb and Dropbox it's mainly a
symbolic paradigm language but it
recently gained support for dynamic
paradigm definitions in tons of flow 2.0
I think other things it has very very
deep Google Cloud integration so if
you're ever on the actual Google cloud
platform and you want to deploy your
model it's pretty easy to with with
tensorflow
one negative is that it's a fairly
low-level library to work with so you
actually gonna be writing and defining
networks in tensorflow you're gonna be
doing a lot of kind of low-level
repetitive things defining a lot of
hyper parameters that you don't wanna
deal with but things like Karis like I
said before I solve this problem then
also like Sanne is another library I'll
go over later one other negatives most
of the API is outside of the core C and
Python library are experimental in
Google's own words or they're mainly
supported through third-party
open-source projects so do with that
what you will if you want to rely on
their java api it exists but it shows
you how much they will actually focus on
it but probably the biggest issue with
tensorflow is its performance tensor
flowed in its design with Google with
all of its like infinite resources and
hardware isn't really that efficient
compared to the other options it tends
to be a resource hog when in terms of
like memory when you actually launch it
other libs can be like twice as fast as
Center flow and certain demon net tasks
you probably really want to avoid it for
like recurrent neural networks or LS TMS
because there are much better options I
mean you would use it just because of
the community out there but really that
it's not that great scaling efficiency
and I mean there are plenty of good
reason to use such a flow and I'm not
trying to convince people not to central
authority as a but this is probably the
only negative and they are actively
working on it they always say that but
there's always kind of like this race of
all the deep learning libraries trying
to be faster than each other and slowly
making improvements as they go intensive
flows that we just kind of been behind
the pack a bit so the next library that
most people think of when they're
comparing to tensorflow is going to be
yeah question in the back
both so tensorflow tends to be slow in
basically all of the computation that
has to do and that tends to add up in
terms of the training time so if you're
just doing inference on a pre trained
net it's still going to do that forward
pass of the net with your input data
slower than most of the other libraries
would and at trading time if you have to
do that millions of times as you go
through all the iterations it adds up
over time so like I said if you have the
money for the resources it's not really
a problem but if you're constrained
until your one machine with your one GPU
and if you want to prototype as fast as
possible it can be an issue so PI torch
and torch so torch was also one of the
early academic focused lives with cafe
but it kind of didn't catch on as much
as cafe did it had a lot of maintain
errs that were at mainly NYU and ended
up going to Facebook when they graduated
PI torch and torch are tied together in
the sense that they use the same
underlying C library so they have very
similar performance but the main
difference is they differ in their
interface where torch uses Lua which is
part of the reason they don't really
catch on as much and Pytor chooses
Python another main advantage of pie
chart over torch is that it has Auto
differentiate audio different
differentiation capabilities and it does
both paradigms whereas torch only does
it symbolic paradigm as you can see
there are still more research citations
in torch just because there's a lot of
earlier research in it but torch but
pipe torch is catching up very fast
and honestly group currently is probably
the most popular library in terms of the
research community with recent research
so pi torch was made with the goal of
kind of fixing and modernizing torch it
has a hybrid front-end so we can use
both symbolic and dynamic paradigms when
you're defining your networks depending
what you're trying to do it has its own
visualization dashboard similar to
tensor board called viz 'dom but they're
also in sensor board forks that work
with pi torch if you're used to that
environment and want to use it it should
probably be avoided if your end goal is
a kind of production environment
application in fact faced and in fact
Facebook actually maintains will used to
maintain a separate library for
production purposes for doing deep
learning called cafe 2 which we'll get
to later who's actually recently merged
into PI torch so they kind of like
combined all their work into one library
finally they are slowly making trees in
spite or to make a more production ready
but they're kind of diverged focus
they're kind of they've fallen behind
the other options when it comes to
production level libraries and like I
said before researchers tend to prefer
PI torch over tensorflow just because it
makes prototyping a really easy
it makes the finding new layers really
easy especially if that's kind of the
main area of focus is defining like new
structures or layers for your network or
like loss functions that do specific
things just probably by torching torch
were kind of like the first to try to
push this dynamic paradigm of model
defining and it kind of verily attracted
a lot of attention because of it and
there's a lot of like I said usage
because of it so the next option which
is also new but also growing fast is MX
net so this is basically Apache and
Amazon's kind of attempt to enter the
whole deep learning library area it has
the largest officially supported API
selection so right as you can see up
here we have Scala our Python C++ julia
close your javascript math matlab and
perl if you ever want to use Perl to do
your deep learning work
there is high compatibility and
consistency through these libraries it
could also like sometimes to a fault so
for example there if you use one API
interface and you switch to another one
you're probably already going to know
how to use it because all the calls are
the same all the structure is the same
but because of that they just kind of
sum cross contamination in design
choices with the API so for example
there's some Python coding patterns
inside the Scala functional API for
example that are kind of not the best to
do but that's how they did it it is a
direct competitor to tensorflow
pretty much across all applications that
can run on everything from a web browser
to a mobile phone it has massive
distributed server farm capabilities and
the key advantage to mx9 is basically
its ability to scale in its performance
amazon has shown and they're trying to
convince people that i mean it is true
that it can scale a like up to 85%
efficiency when you keep throwing adding
GPUs to the to your cluster which is
great and also generally it's single GPU
performance is also very good from most
online benchmarks comparing all of them
it has its own serving framework similar
to tensorflow serving and has deep
integration with AWS so if you're in the
a double yes environment and you want to
do things like training on their sage
maker platform or like deploying to
their own stuff it makes it pretty easy
as its own sensor board Forks if you
want to visualize your training process
and get all that working well yes yes so
theoretically scaling efficiencies so
say you have one GPU and you want to add
a second GPU to your server or cluster
to speed up your training process with
85% scaling efficiency that means when
you add a second GPU you'll get a 85%
speed increase as opposed to a hundred
percent speed increase which would be
theoretically the limit of your
potential speed increase by adding more
resources to your cluster so depending
on how the underlying library works in
terms of trading information between all
of your available GPUs and like
networked together or on the same
machine you can lose some efficiencies
there and basically Amazon's found that
they were the best in terms of scaling
with up to 85 percent efficiency when
you start adding GPUs and so they have
the minimal overhead so em excellent
also has a second Python interface along
with their original interface called
mx-9 gluon it was created in a
collaboration between AWS and Microsoft
it provides a more high-level clear
concise and simple API for defining deep
neural nets whereas the raw emic set api
can be fairly low level like tensorflow
it has a bunch of predefined layers and
optimizers and initialized for you to
use and has its own built-in models ooh
that's separate from the MX from the raw
and makes that one that's actually
better it has hybridization which is
probably the best feature about it so
like pi torture has a hybrid symbolic
and dynamic graph model for defining our
networks but you can actually gain the
advantages of both at the same time so
you can for example define your entire
network and the gluon high dynamic
framework and then say when you're done
debugging testing and writing your code
you can just call dot hybridize on your
entire net and it'll go through on the
back end and reconstruct the entire
thing as a symbolic net then you gain
all the advantages of speed and resource
management without changing any of your
code in fact you can actually even break
it down so it only does that for parts
of your network so say you are working
on a network and you know the first part
of your feature extraction network it's
pretty typical and there's nothing
really to work on there but you're
working on a new loss layer at the very
end we need to do some weird things you
can call hybridize on just the first
part of that and I work so crazy
symbolic network there are so going to
all the optimizations but then the very
end of your network it's still dynamic
so you can still drop in do your break
statements do some weird logic flow
around there and because of this gluon
can be up to three times as fast as pi
torch we're doing similar dynamic work
because they can go on its own back-end
do some optimizations symbolically when
it can
it has great documentation for absolute
beginners for gluons so basically it's a
pretty good online book that will walk
you through like a lot of the math knee
and the internals of glue on and kind of
like walk you through creating things as
simple of like linear regression models
with going on all the way up to like
convolutional neural networks from
scratch and LS TMS and to do things like
classification I like object detection a
bunch of NLP problems basically you
should always use glue on over raw
Python API if you're using MX net if you
ever get the chance so issues with MX
net the non Python API yeah no it's
actually inside the MX net like
repository itself there are two Python
the API is hosted on their github repo
so you can call the the normal ones
called the module API which is what all
the languages share they all share the
module API but the gluon api is only
defined in python and it's completely
built from the ground up separately just
to address a bunch of issues like the
module api for all the other languages
are only symbolic so you can't do all
the fancy guy dynamic graph stuff and
use the advantages of like the hyper
today ssin for all the layers and like
and it generally it's a fairly low-level
api for all the other languages so yeah
so use the glue on if you're using
python otherwise if you're using
something like r or julia or pearl then
you have to use the module API so
disadvantages with MX net all the non
python api s are kind of lacking in
certain aspects the documentation is
weaker the stability issues when you
start throwing like full production
skill low it at it it can fall apart a
bit the community is small but it's so
growing but it's really never the first
library to be used for like open source
projects or like reap limitations of
research papers so if there's some cool
thing that came out from like nips or
something and you want to get using as
fast as possible but you don't really
know how to implement yourself you're
probably have to be waiting a while for
someone to do it in MX nuts because
they'll probably do in pythor tour or
tend to flow first
so next we have CNT K which is
Microsoft's attempt at making a deep
note a deep learning library it stands
for the Microsoft cognitive toolkit
which was originally created by MSR
speech researchers to do NLP type
problems recently and up to this point
it has been expanded to do all types of
deep learning applications and kind of
their own in-house deep learning library
that they work with it's used for things
like Skype Xbox Cortana basically
anything a sure that's our pointing that
they're like pushing out nowadays like
hololens or like Kinect and I was and as
your things have an Xbox thing it's has
a main focus on NLP from the beginning
and because of that it has honestly
unbeatable Arnon and like Alice TM
performance just because of some design
choices that they make in terms of how
dynamically sized input and outputs are
passed around between the layers that
are kind of cumbersome to do when
tensorflow but are just very easy to do
and kind of expected in cm TK it
supports for distributed training like
tensorflow
in fact they have like papaya terry one
bit stochastic gradient descent
algorithm that actually significantly
improves training performance when
you're working on their hardware and
probably the biggest reason why people
use it is that it's the only library
with first cath class Windows support
because it's made by Microsoft in fact
it doesn't even support OSX officially
it only supports Windows and Linux it
has very simple azor deployment
solutions and if you're using a dotnet
language because you love c-sharp this
is the library for you but of course it
also works with R and Python and C++
since Microsoft is fairly invested in
all those languages as well it has the
average size models ooh honestly and a
pretty good documentation which is
consistent with most other MSDN
documentation type of problems I mean
there are better ones
it has a non-conventional
open-source license history which is
kind of expected with Microsoft they've
gotten better now they push over there
like everything over to MIT but like
certain aspects of the library aren't
open-source so it gets kind of a little
weird if you're trying to get into your
own production
it has a fairly small community as you
can see by the research citations like
honestly it is going to be the least
used option in research generally most
of those citations are probably from MSR
themselves so but there's also code
examples on the right it works like I
said there's works as a Karass back end
so there's example there did you put but
python an r and there's a standard
Python example if you want to use the
low-level library so one of the library
to kind of keep track of while we're
going through all of these is onyx so
onyx stands for the open neural net
exchange format basically it was created
in collaboration with AWS Facebook and
Microsoft notably Google's absent and
it's a library that's used for
transferring models in between different
libraries with a standardized serialize
format so basically if you train in one
like M so like if you're trading in MX
net you can load your model into onyx
and then spit it out into PI torch or cm
TK if you want to or it also supports a
bunch of other libraries including
tensor flow just not officially from
Google themselves along with some other
options that we'll get to get to but
it's a very useful tool and you should
definitely use it if you have existing
work that you want to transfer over to
new libraries so a performance compare
e.a a performance comparison summary so
here is a pretty useful archive paper
from - of 2017 so it's a little old so
things have changed but it's very well
done
it compares cm TK attend torch Cafe mx9
and tensorflow and it compares them all
on CPUs single GPUs multiple GPUs and it
tests the both synthetic and real data
they come us be working with and it kind
of covers all the standard deepness
architectures that we've gone over and
just to see what performs best we're in
kind of a quick paper summary just to
kind of get an idea like what the
performance comparisons are between the
libraries so for single GPU tasks cafe c
n TK and torch all perform better than
Amex and tensor flow on fully connected
Network tasks MX net has the best
performance in terms of convolutional
neural network tasks especially when the
size of those networks are growing and
growing with the deep network layers and
also the size of your input
where's cafe and Sina TK also achieve
good performance but only on the smaller
size of the CNN's you can work with RN
ends in LS teams like I said before Sen
TK can not be beat it has almost 5 to 10
times faster speed than some of the
other options at certain tasks when
working with multiple GPUs like I said
before MX net and torch tend to scale
the best with I'm excited beating out
torch slightly denser flow scales the
worst CNT K performs better at scaling
with fully connected networks and the
other ones but you generally won't ever
be really working with flink fully
connected Network since more of a
synthetic data task or if you're working
with like vector eyes and input to try
to do simple production on some of the
libraries have library specific
optimizations that others don't
especially when you're working with
symbolic defined graphs so examples CNT
K and M X and both have the ability to
optimize heavily the network at compile
time to take advantage of a memory you
have and how much hardware resources you
essentially have over all that it can
take up and overall like I said before
the performance of tensor flow tends to
be trailing behind all the other options
which is really it's only in biggest
negative so those are kind of the main
ones but those aren't the only options
out there and there are other libraries
to probably take note of and are
relevant if you care about them so we
have piano and this will kind of go
about by quicker so this is a Python
library it was also one of the early
academic libraries it has ended
development in fact there was a pretty
somber blog post from the developers
when they decided to do this where
they're kind of bowing out of the
competition between at the time PI torch
and tensorflow is saying that there
really isn't a reason for them to keep
working on it with these better options
out there so they decided to commit
their own time to working on those
libraries instead though there's a lot
of early research that was done in it in
fact it is responsible for spawning off
Karos and some other high-level deep
learning libraries that are built on top
of it so it is a very important history
you can still use the anno currently
today with Karros here's some code
examples but really you should never
use it over tensorflow unless you're
specifically working with old code and
you need to use it for a weird reason
you have cafe to which i mentioned
before which originally was the
maintainer of cafe graduated from
Berkeley went to Facebook to start
working and started working on cafe 2
after he got there and eventually like I
said it got merged into PI torch Cafe 2
was designed from the beginning to focus
on production applications so it's very
good at scaling from mobile devices all
the way to multiple GPU farms it
improves over cafe in a lot of areas so
as a differentiation is first-class
support for a large-scale distributed
training or cafe was really only single
computer solutions it could do multiple
computer solutions but it's kind of not
that great it has better modern hardware
support it has a lot more flexibility in
terms of the in terms of using things
like quantized computation which
basically quantized computation is if
you want to take your network and remove
the floating-point accuracy of the
individual computations inside your
network to gain speed for the trade-off
of a bit of accuracy and it has been
stress tested by the vast scale of
Facebook applications and Facebook uses
it internally for their own stuff we
have fast AI so fast AI is a library
that is built on top of PI torch fast AI
this main goal is essentially to be a
learning tool for people looking to get
into research it is a library that's
focused on basically the best practices
are doing deep learning they offer a
very good free online and yearly updated
set of courses on their website it'll
teach you everything you need to know
about deep learning and you can even
take an in-person course if you're in
San Francisco this year it's the first
time that they're doing it there you're
probably the quickest at integrating new
research kind of ideas and getting
examples out from my experience and it's
like I said it's very good for beginners
who are getting into research and one of
them kind of master the topic this is
where you want to start because you'll
get to know why torture very well after
doing this and fast I kind of abstract
slow the price or PI toward stuff in the
beginning and slowly introduced as you
went to the lower
and library you have core ml so this is
Apple's a deep learning library it's not
a full deep learning library really it's
clearly closed sourced and it you can't
do training in it really it's only used
for deploying previously trained models
to Apple hardware so like your iPhones
or your mac books you need to use a
different deep learning library to train
your model and then they have their own
provided tools to convert things from
like Kerris a cafe scikit-learn Lib SV
MXG boost MX net tensor flow into the
core ml format and Cornell is also
supported by onyx so you can pretty much
get any model into a iPhone now but this
is really the best way to run your
models on iOS hardware so if that's your
end production goal this is really why
you should look into there are some
other options but they're not really
that performant core core ml can use a
lot of native advantages that Apple has
and it can you read in Swift and
Objective C which is the only options
for really running on iOS we have the
deep learning tool box by MATLAB so it
is a MATLAB toolbox for implementing
CNN's and LST M it has pretty good GPU
support and it can even do cloud GPUs on
AWS with a separate tool box that is the
distributive computing toolbox it has a
lot of nice visualizations and tools you
can create visualize analyze deep
learning networks and their architecture
and structure with their own interactive
apps it's very useful for training they
have their own model zoo you can even
load in models from onyx and cafe and
tensorflow directly with to a box but
with everything MATLAB it's expensive so
it's close source and you have to buy
the tool box from MATLAB and either a
annual license for 500 bucks or a
perpetual license for $1,200 so if
you're in a lab and they're paying for
your MATLAB license already because
you're in a university great use this
it's probably not that bad of an
experience to work with but honestly
there's a bunch of open source and free
Python and our options out there that
you should probably use instead but if
all your codes already in MATLAB here
you go
there's an option for you deep learning
for J for people who don't know that
there's a world outside of the JVM
so is written with the JVM in mind so
it's target API languages are Scala and
Java probably one day they'll get to
Kotlin it has native cara support if you
want to train in Python but the end
result is always gonna be in Java it is
mainly focused on enterprise and getting
things out into your JVM application it
takes advantage of a lot of distributed
computing frameworks so if you're
working with Hadoop or Apache spark this
is an option for you I'm excellent also
has integration with a patchy spark if
you want to run deep learning on your
spark cluster and you can also natively
import models from tensorflow
and I think cafe as well but it's pretty
good performance very good documentation
and honestly I think they deserve more
uses than they actually get just because
they're very niche in their application
but it's a very good library trainer not
much to say about chain ER it is a
library from a Japanese startup that was
fairly early on it got some research
usage early on when people were using it
it was one of the first libraries have a
dynamic graph computation interface like
pi torch did apparently it's used by IBM
and until for some things really even a
lot of a reason to use trainer over any
of the other options I mean if you need
a Japanese documentation for it maybe
that's why but outside of it I would
skip it dark net dark net is a very
small open-source effort by very
laid-back dev groups so basically it is
a project by a group out of the
University of Washington I think where
it's basically really more of a exercise
by the lab itself to create their own
deep learning library so they can do
everything and know how everything works
they're like it's a very laid back the
entire repo is filled with emojis all of
their PRS are kind of ridiculous but
it's used in some of their own research
that is notable and probably one key
thing is that the main maintainer of
this repo has written my favorite
research paper ever it's hilarious and
everybody should read it if you get the
chance
sonot so SONET is the other library
built on top of 10 to flow that I
mentioned it before it's similar to
Karis and that it's really to make using
tons flow easier but this one is
developed by Google deep
which is one of the probably the biggest
names and the AI industry research they
are behind things like alphago which is
the first AI to beat a professional go
player they are behind alpha star which
is the first AI to be de I don't know if
it's personal but a notable AI to be a
professional Starcraft player in real
time really like I said it's built on
sensor flow it makes a neural net
construction and training easy and
extensible it's really just the deep
mind guy is making their own library
because they know what they want to do
and they want to do it their way
you can use it yourself there isn't a
lot of use in it I mean there's some
publication research but it's all out of
deepmind so if you really want to work
with d-minor get into deep mind probably
start using this quenette jl this is a
julia only deep learning library if you
love Julia and want to use it basically
the only reason you use this is if you
want to use kind of the expressiveness
of Julia in your model definitions so
like things like helper functions
conditionals recursions and closures
that's about it it has pretty good
performance not as good as the other
options but if you are Julia developer
and you want to get to deep learning
here's an option for you paddle
so paddle stands for the parallel
distributed deep learning package it is
made by Baidu it has a per as a mainly
Chinese documentation that's been
translated into English it was
originally developed by Baidu for their
own in-house AI application so like
Baidu is essentially the Google of China
so all of their own applications use
this for the machine learning tasks on
their back-end really you would only use
this if you are in that market or
ecosystem already and are familiar with
I guess how they do things so for most
probably most of this room this is an
option that you could probably ignore
cob net je s so this is a library for
doing deep neural training deep neural
net training in your browser if that's
something you'd ever want to do it's
mainly used for like teaching purposes
so it's very helpful for like
visualizing and the training process of
your neural net in browsers basically it
was created by Stanford for their deep
for their in machine learning class to
help teach people you can actually start
training a network by just clicking that
link
and I will start training in your
browser a Seafarer classification
network really that's about it I would
also advise taking the Stanford class if
you're trying to learn it's a very
useful tool they provide all the notes
and all the lecture videos and all the
homework that you can do it yourself
neon
so neon is Intel's attempt I'm making a
deepen a deep learning library it is
written with specific it was written
after they acquired a company called
Nirvana and is written specifically with
mkl which is their linear algebra
library hardware in mind so your Xeon
and your and you if you've ever seen
those Phi computation boards and Intel
makes that are kind of like GPUs but not
GPUs but you so plug the miniature
computer the same way processors really
it's the only reason why you would use
neon is if you have one of those five
processes or you're really trying to get
the best speed out of your Xeon server
it has one of the best performances out
there because that's always been the
main focus of this library and
development is speed they were one of
the first libraries to do like half
floating-point precision calculation or
even quantization on their training
process but yeah it's interesting but
I've never used it and I probably won't
and it's only a Python library so
dinette this is the last one that's
probably taken note of its by Stanford I
mean it's like Carnegie Mellon it's used
for some of their research not much to
say about it use dynamic computation
graph and that's why it's named that so
basically a tldr so if you're looking to
do most things you could probably go
with tensorflow
it's especially for like industry like
production related things if you care
more about your speed you're a good
developer like you're willing to deal
with some of the bugs are like figuring
out some things that most community
won't be able to help you with look into
MX net and gluon because you'll
definitely gain some things there
especially if you're using one of the
non-standard
API languages that max net supports over
tensorflow use PI torch if you're doing
a research that is probably the easiest
suggestion there if you're just getting
started you wanna get started as fast as
possible look in the chaos if you're
getting started but you want to learn as
much as possible look in a fast a I if
you're in the world
of Windows and visual studio and dotnet
looking to see ntk especially if you're
doing NLP but don't do stand Takei if
you're specifically only doing NLP the
other options are also good as well just
not as fast use core ml for deploying
Apple devices and use deep learning for
J if you really like the JVM and just to
help it out a bit more I've created this
nice flow chart that you can help decide
what deeply deep learning library is
best for you I don't know if you can
read it back there but I will publish
this later and a way that you can look
in yourself so yeah that's it so I guess
we have time for questions or something
yes
so most so it so especially with CUDA
devices on your GPU most things are done
in 32-bit floating-point accuracy or
even 64 but if you want to do double
precision switching to half position you
lose some accuracy but you gain a lot of
speeds and simplifies the underlying
mathematical computation that the GPU
has to do which for most things if
you're not like doing like very specific
like astronomical level calculations is
not that important
that might be the case I haven't
honestly kept up with it since the last
time I looked into it so yeah yeah yeah
exactly
I'm not I have seen it I'm not familiar
with it really so I can't really talk
much about it if has it jumped out to me
for a reason that it's probably a reason
for that but I don't know
different libraries will always give
different results just because of the
underlying way they do the calculations
I wouldn't never say that one library
leads to more accurate code in the end
since the more has to do with the
specific implementations that the writer
of your models or your algorithms
chooses to do like maybe some libraries
make it easier to do certain things and
that changes your code but really the
main difference would less be accuracy
and more be speed is the main thing to
worry about in terms of your models oh
yeah so I never said that so after this
entire process we ended up going so
originally we were using cafe for a few
years and it was kind of pain we started
early using cafe just because that's
what the models we were using or
originally trained with we ended up
maintaining our own interface for cafe
which is a real pain because all of our
production code is in Scala in JVM so we
wrote our own C++ the Scala API for cafe
maintained it internally and all that
was a painted all the binary stuff you
have to maintain for that so after doing
all this we ended up going with MX nut
over tensorflow those were the last two
options we were kind of deftly comparing
against back and forth mainly just
because the big thing was that MX net
supports Scala directly where is 410
supply we would have had to go through
the Java API which is not that great
compared to the Scala API in MX net and
all of our tech stack is actually in AWS
already so we have a pretty good
relation with the AWS AI team which
maintains their brant they're part of MX
in it so there's a little bit bias there
but
yeah so the question was if there's any
significant difference from loading one
model from one library to another
depending on how complicated the model
can be you might actually run into
issues where you get completely
different outputs depending on how good
the conversion software is so if you're
doing more simple kind of like CNN's all
the libraries are pretty standardized on
how to do that so you're gonna get like
identical networks on the other side
performance wise having certain models
defined in a certain way on one library
that was more efficient for that library
probably won't be efficient for the
other libraries so you will will lose
some performance there so honestly in my
experience when it comes to transferring
models from one library to another I
have more often than not just retrain
the entire model and just say if I
already have the code and framework set
up to do it I'll just rewrite the
training code in the other library and
there's set it off for the weekend and
come back and look at it and I'll get
similar performance but it's yeah that
is an option yes that's not always an
option especially if you're looking at
types of models of like image Annette
where it takes like weeks to Train you
never want to do that again but yeah so
generally assuming you have a pretty
basic and not like custom model
framework it should be similar
performance it might not always be the
same it's because of some underlying
things but it would never be drastically
wrong
so the thing with Karis is our back end
it the main event is is that it does
give you all those options so if you're
but you really lose the performance
advantages when you're using carrots
because like I said earlier it can't
construct to the underlying graph in a
efficient way for the underlying library
even though it is only symbolic it still
has to translate all of its
interpretation of the network into all
of the other underlying frameworks
interpretation and it's never going to
be the most efficient so if you're ever
looking at benchmarks that compare like
Cara's tensorflow to just raw tensorflow
it's always faster on tensorflow and
it's the same story for like C and D K
and M X net and piano when you're using
those backends but yeah the main
advantages is that you can switch
assuming that all of the layers and
operations that you're trying to do in
Cara's are supported and care us but
like I said before sometimes you do have
to go down into the native library to do
some things if you're getting a more
advanced and then you lose the advantage
there being abstracted away from the
lower-level library
yes so if you're doing something is like
just simple CNN's you will get best
performance out of the MX net back-end
in the tensorflow back-end oh like all
the time so yeah so for a for for AWS
the answer is MX not just because it's
the library that they themselves
maintain so things like if you've ever
used Sage maker which is their kind of
cloud training platform their branch of
MX net on Sage maker runs faster than
all the other libraries because it's
directly accelerated for their hardware
in fact amazon offers custom tensor
inference hardware called elastic eight
called elastic and forensics elevators
that work with MX net natively and also
there's a branch of tensile flow that
they maintain themselves to enable it
but it's not as maintained as the MX net
version which is a cheaper way to train
on the cloud as opposed to using a GPU
Google off also offer something very
similar with their TP use and tensor
flow on Google Cloud so that's the
reason to use such a blog Google Cloud
as for Azure like I said before C and TK
is Microsoft's own version and that
works easily the best with Azure
especially if you're working with like
dotnet stuff and deploying on there so
generally you're not going to go wrong
with the owner of the cloud services own
platform the only other cloud server
you're gonna run into outside of those
three is gonna be like IBM or HP and IBM
does I guess use chainer but don't use
that just probably you sense your flow
if you're on IBM cloud
so no movie the last question of the
night so the main thing has to do with
the structure of the nets so for a
convolutional neural net you can fix the
entire size of the net so you have a
standard image size be like 256 by 256
is your input and that structure of the
Nets never going to change I mean it can
change with fully comba leash fully
convolutional neural Nets which is a
kind of an offshoot of convolutional
neural nets where there are no fully
connected layers and whatsoever so it
can actually change in size since every
operations is a kernel but for our n
ends and LS TMS when they're feeding
into themselves the output of each layer
above each iteration is never going to
be the same in terms of size so it has
to kind of re adapt itself and
especially with LS TM to does some very
crazy things with gates on the inside
like the memory management that are
never the same between one iteration of
the net to the next one as it goes
through the entire time series so
especially with that kind of looping
logic and everything it's a lot more
natural to use it in a dynamic paradigm
that is your PI torches of the world
than it is to try to force it in so like
I said like cafe it's possible to do RN
ends with it's a weird 1/2 to get it
working
all of the modern libraries can do all
the RNN type problems it's just some do
it better than others from just
underlying design choices when they were
making the library so for your cm
Takei's of the world that was their main
focus going from the beginning so a lot
of like the low-level just like things
like padding your outputs from like one
to another and see in Lexington K is
much easier to deal with in a tensor
flow which is kind of a pain whereas
like piped or to somewhere in the middle
and yeah so it's possible to do like
Google on mx9 has an entire NLP library
to work with you can do almost
everything in it it's just it's
abstracted away from you so most the
time you don't have to worry about that
kind of a thing but you're gonna lose
performance and that's just kind of the
main trade-off
[Applause]